NARRATOR: In the rugged
peaks of Northern Alaska,
Marty Meierotto is
beating back mother nature
to reclaim a decades-old
trap line that's
been neglected for years.
But with night coming on fast,
he's hit a road block of brush.
This is a lot worse
patch than I thought.
I thought I'd be
through this quick.
NARRATOR: He's been working to
clear it for more than an hour
in temperatures of 20 below.
[saw buzzing]
Take off this jacket.
I just do not want
to start sweating.
NARRATOR: Sweating
in subzero conditions
can lead to hypothermia
in a matter of minutes.
But he can't slow down.
He's got three more miles
to clear to reach shelter
or be left out in the cold.
[saw buzzing]
Ha, my chain flew off.
[breathes heavily]
Damn it!
NARRATOR: Extreme
cold wreaks havoc
on machinery, as
the blade contracts,
and the chain
expands from overuse.
Have to get it really tight--
pretty much brand new chain.
They're all eating time.
Daylights, it matters right
now for this kind of weather.
I can't see.
I can't cut.
I'm not going to
cut in the dark.
Good way to get hurt.
There we go.
All right.
[saw buzzing]
Taking a lot longer
than what I had hoped.
But I just got to
keep pushing on.
[saw buzzing]
Ah.
I just broke the chain.
And I don't have another one.
I blew it.
We are done.
[suspenseful music]
NARRATOR: In Alaska, with his
chainsaw out of commission
and night coming on
fast, Marty works
to clear the wall of
brush with the only set
of tools he has left--
his hands.
But I want to at
least get through today.
OK.
See the opening up there.
[breathes heavily]
All right, want to keep going.
[blows air]
A lot of this stuff,
I can drive over.
All right, we're off.
[motor noise]
I'll just keep pushing
on and hopefully
not run into too much more.
If I'm lucky, so I make it
to the cabin before dark.
[motor noise]
NARRATOR: Three miles ahead,
Marty finally reaches the cabin
he hasn't laid eyes on
since he last trapped
this area four years ago.
Well, it's still standing.
Man.
Bears chewed there.
Ah, the place is trashed.
NARRATOR: While Marty was
away, the critters took over.
MARTY MEIEROTTO: Dang squirrels.
They ate my sleeping bag up.
There's nothing in it.
Look at the sleeping pad--
ate right through one,
two, three of them.
Shht.
Yeah, the neighbors weren't
kind to my shoes either.
Ha, ha, ha-- they
couldn't get those--
the turds-- get those good.
You know, the cabin's trashed.
But I'm cleaning it up.
So I'm OK.
I'm safe.
It will make a place to
sleep if nothing else.
It's livable.
I'll be able to spend the night.
That's something.
Now, I just need to concentrate
on getting my line back.
I got to start catching fur.